مستمرين معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه تطورات
الحادثه المؤسفه لقرش الغردقه اللي انها
حياه الشاب الروسي فلاديمير بوفوف وعمره
23 سنه امس كنا تكلمنا عن تقرير وزاره
البيئه اللي طلع وقالت فيه انه القرش هجم
على الشاب بدافع التغذيه وكمان طلع معانا
مسؤول في وزاره البيئه ورد على كل
المتداول حول الحادثه ووضح الحقائق
الجديده اليوم انه معهد علوم البحار قرر
البدء بعمليات تحنيط سمكه القرش من قبل
علماء المعهد ليتم وضعها لاحقا في متحف
علوم البحار بالغردقه او اللي تابع للمعهد
نفسه
في المقطع اللي شفتوه بيظهر علماء حول
القرش واحد بيعمل شقوق في جسمها وواحد
ثاني بيفحص الجلد وظاهر كمان في الفيديو
ماده بيضاء في فم القرش واللي بتستخدم في
التحنيطا مشاهدينا انه هذا القرش تم
اصطياده بعد قتله للشاب الروسي وبحسب
السلطات تم استخراج من معدته راس وذراعي
وصدر الشاب اما نصف الثاني في الصيادين
استخرجوا من مياه البحر والروايه بتقول ان
القرش اللي من نوع تايجر كان في طريقه انه
ياكل الشاب كاملا لكن لما بدا يقترب قارب
احد الصيادين ترك نصفه الثاني في الماء
وهرب قبل ما يرجعوا يصيدوا ويقتلوه طيب
عموما ومع تداول فيديو تحنيط القرش كثار
تساءلوا ايش سبب التحنيط واللي راح يعرض
القرش فيه او القرش في متحف اصلا في
تفاعلكم احنا تواصلنا مع المعهد القومي
للعلوم والبحار وهذا رد احد الاساتذه فيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبيتم تحميتها لعرضها على الجمهور فيما
بعد احنا عندنا معروضات موجوده في المتحف
لاسماك قرش ودلافين وعروسه
البحر وانواع محنطات بحريه اخرى من
الثلاثينات ما كانش في حاجه جايه نتيجه
لحادث
قتل انسان كانت حاجات جايه نافقه
وفي حاجات كانت جايه على وشك الموت بسبب
كبر السن وفي حاجات كانت جايه نتيجه لصراع
بين الكائنات البحريه مع بعضها
اللي احنا في عمليه التحليط بنزيل كل
اللحم اللي موجود في السمكه والعظم
وبنكتفي بالجلد والفك بس وبيتم ازاله كل
اللحوم عشان ما تتعفنش
بقايا اللحوم بيتم تجفيفها بالملح بحيث ان
اي رطوبه داخل جلد السمكه بيتم التخلص
منها
وبعدين بيتم
الصبغ اللحم بماده مره اسمها البوركس عشان
عشان الجلد بعد كده ما يسوسش وبعد كده
بيتم حشوها بنشاره الخشب
وتتقفل على الشكل الطبيعي بتاع السمك
الاصلي
[موسيقى]